this program is brought to you by Emory
University
that's what the the support
and being here Grady does for you it
validates you you feel like yes I am a
person with lupus
I'm not lupus but I am a person with
lupus and I am just as different as the
next person is but we have a likeness we
have something that each of us can
relate to and it helps so much you just
don't realize how much it helps to know
somebody like you being here at Grady
what it did different from me was
introduced me to people just like me and
when I say just like me I don't mean
that we all have lupus I mean that here
in the support group that I've been in
everybody has the same attitude that I
am that let's keep it moving
let's do what we can and we can look at
one another and tell them we're not
feeling our best we know but you have
that attitude to keep it going
you
the preceding program is
Marie University